you
hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast the role of sirt1
LX our alpha beta signaling and diabetic
retinopathy presented by dr. Sandra
hammer Research Fellow Michigan State
University I'm Kristy dual of laberd's
and I'll be your moderator for today's
event today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by laberd's and sponsored
by the Fisher get Co get Co cell culture
heroes is a program putting PhD and
postdoc researchers around the world in
the spotlight for more information on
our sponsor please visit thermo Fisher
comm forward slash cell culture heroes
now let's get started I would like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive and we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation to do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box and click send you can also see at
the top of the page multiple tabs please
click through our related applications
upcoming and on-demand webinars as well
as links to the cell culture heroes
webpage you may be our next so culture
hero also please notice that you can
share this webinar on your personal
social media just click on the social
sharing tab to let your friends and
colleagues know about today's live event
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation click on the support
tab sound at the top right of the
presentation window or report your
problem by clicking on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen
this presentation is educational and the
software is continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
your presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits I would
now like to introduce today's presenter
dr. Sandra hammer research fellow
Michigan State University dr. Hamburg is
a postdoctoral fellow in the Busic
laboratory at Michigan State University
prior to being at MSU she attended
Vanderbilt University where she obtained
a PhD in cell and developmental biology
under the mentorship of John Penn prior
to this she received her BS degree from
the University of Miami for a complete
biography on dr. Kammer please visit the
biography tab at the top of your screen
dr. hammer you may now begin your
presentation
great so thanks so much for that
introduction Christy hi everyone my name
is Sandra hammer
I am a postdoc in the beauty Club at
Michigan State University
so before diving into my research I just
wanted to thank the get-go and the lab
routines for this awesome opportunity
today to share my work on this platform
so today I'm going to be talking about
the research that I'm doing in the Busic
lab and it really centers on lipid
dysregulation specifically looking at
cholesterol metabolism in diabetic
retinopathy which we will get into in a
little bit
although my current work and the Busic
Labs focuses on this lipedema and
cholesterol trying to understand these
early driving mechanisms of diabetic
retinopathy progression have really been
of great interest to me since I started
graduate school in 2011 and in 2015 I
got my PhD in song development biology
from Vanderbilt and and I was looking at
the effect of high glucose in retinal
pary sunny apoptosis and this is
interesting to me because retinal
parasite apoptosis is one of the first
histone pathological events that happens
disease so it's really early on in
disease and after doing all of this work
with high glucose I which is one of the
metabolic insults that lead to D our
progression I wanted to switch gears a
little bit and that led me to the work
of dr. Julia Busic and she really is the
pioneer in lipid and cholesterol
dysregulation diabetes so i'm why
why study about diet diabetic
retinopathy this disease is actually a
diabetes city epidemic that is obesity
and type 2 diabetes is likely to be the
biggest epidemic in human history and if
you can see from this slide it is
estimated than a year 2040 over six
hundred and forty million adults are
going to be living with this disease and
what's even scarier is that 70 million
of these individuals are going to have
this vision threatening diabetic
retinopathy so trying to figure out
mechanisms that cause disease
progression are really really important
in trying to figure out ways to treat
the earlier stage of disease to prevent
the 70 million patients to lose their
vision now a diabetic pathogenesis it is
like I mentioned before the leading
cause of blindness among working age
adults and it affects the blood vessels
in the retina this disease really
affects all of retina healthy function
my work really focuses on the blood
vessels and that is because the damage
that we see to the blood vessels are the
ones that we tend to see in the patients
that have this vision threatening stage
of the disease so we believe that it's
really important trying to fix these
abnormalities in the blood vessels are
really important to stopping the
progression of DR what I'm showing here
is a normal retina to the left and you
can see the fovea the macula all are
necessary for this high acuity vision
and on the right you have the diabetic
retinopathy retina and you can see that
unlike the nice healthy retina there's a
lot of spots where you have hemorrhages
or the abnormal growth of blood vessels
as well as information of aneurysm so
all of these pathologies if they're left
untreated can then cause vision loss in
this high percent of the population so
decades of research on diabetic
retinopathy pathogenesis has led to a
lot of really effective and commonly
used treatment options for dr the first
is a retinal photocoagulation and this
is laser therapy so if you take a laser
be
and you burn small laser spots in the
retina and this really diminishes the
demand of oxygen the retina is consuming
so this leads to a dramatic decrease in
the amount of abnormal blood vessel
growth which as I showed in the previous
slide was one of the complications that
you see in the end stage of the disease
since laser therapy there has been more
more of efficacious therapies and that
is primarily done with anti Avastin
athelia growth factor or anti veg f
injections and since 2004 we have
different flavors of anti adjustments
and injections all of these are really
effective in treating the disease but
they are not perfect there's still a
large percentage of the population with
this disease that are not responsive to
that Jeff and more and more studies are
coming out that in some parts of the
retina veg F is actually needed for
healthy retinal function so if you're
getting rid of all the veg F that could
then cause other effects so my work
really right now is focusing on
dyslipidemia and a lot of work has been
done trying to understand the effect
that high sugar has on VR progression
and not a lot is not about disability so
this lipid dysregulation results as an
imbalance from regulation of lipid
uptake metabolism released and also
clearance from the circulation and this
at this problem is seen in both type 1
and type 2 patients so in type 2 you
have this insulin resistance but in type
1 you have low portal insulin so all of
these dysregulation and insulin can have
really significant effect on plasma
lipid levels lipid profiles and fatty
acid composition so several clinical
trials on here I am highlighting one
work but there's been many clinical
trials that have shown that diabetic
dyslipidemia is characterized by
elevated levels of most
lipid classes you have triglyceride
sphingolipids cholesterol for the
purpose of my work I'm going to be
focusing on the role that cholesterol
has on D our progression so very briefly
an overview of cholesterol this is a
lipid composed of a four ranked system
it is mainly associated with membranes
and it forms these multi molecular
complexes and they are transported
through the systemic circulation as you
can see highlighted here
so the retina is very unique unlike
other peripheral tissues like the brain
for instance that primarily used
definitely locally synthesized
cholesterol their retina actually has
three different ways to regulate
cholesterol homeostasis so it either
does it by system systemic control but
it can also produce cholesterol and can
also eliminate cholesterol and under
healthy conditions most of the
cholesterol has been shown to come into
this retinal pigment epithelium lab
layer however in diabetic conditions
you also have cholesterol coming in
through the endothelial cell layer and
this is important because in diabetic
retinopathy you have this increase in
the calash accumulation suggesting that
we have some kind of imbalance in the
amount of cholesterol coming in and the
ability of the retina to take it out so
all of these different mechanisms should
really emphasize the importance that you
haven't been tainted endogenous
cholesterol biosynthesis and this is
really important because studies have
previously got rid of all of the retinal
cholesterol and if you do that you
actually have retinal degeneration so we
don't want to promote all of the
elimination of cholesterol we just want
to go back to those healthy levels and
one of the ways that you can achieve
this is by modulating this key regulator
of cholesterol homeostasis known as lxr
and this is one of my favorite nuclear
receptors that I'll be talking about
today so there's two isoforms of lxr you
have alpha and beta
these are nuclear sensors so the way
that it works is I'm cell there oxy
sterols and these are casseras are just
metabolites of cholesterol they
accumulate as you have more cholesterol
and once the oxy sterols bind to lxr it
becomes activated and activation of elux
are then promotes the activation of the
reverse cholesterol transport so it's
basically activates pathways that are
going to get rid of that excess
cholesterol in the tissue and we've
previously shown our collaborators have
shown that lxr is an important regulator
so if you if you activate lxr and sgz
mice f2z is a type one model of diabetic
diabetes in animals
if you activate LX r you can prevent the
our pathology and what we're showing
here is an acellular capillary this is a
hallmark of D our progression animal and
if you look at panel D you can see that
there is less white the white arrows are
hi are highlighting the a cell or
capillary formation which is increase in
diabetes of panel C so you can see that
the animal is treated with an Alex or
activator have less of these suggesting
that these animals have less diabetic
induced damage than the diabetics
counterpart
shown here again all three both alpha
and beta as well as the double knockout
are all important so suggesting that
both isoforms are very important in
regulating cholesterol and what we've
shown my data and has shown that not
only does diabetes and decrease lxr and
in mice but we can also see that in
human and de Sciglio cells and the way
that we do this that we take human
retina so you have a non diabetic retina
and a diabetic retina you can see again
the formation of those hemorrhages in
the diabetic retina and you take these
retinas and you isolate retinal
necessarily ourselves from them and you
with PCR you then look at expression
levels of lxr and you can see that in
the diabetic there is a decrease in onyx
or alpha and lxr beta so looking at
these oxy steroids like I mentioned
earlier these are endogenous activators
relics are so I'm shown here I'm just
showing them once in green these are the
flavors of these artist areas that are
activators for lxr so not only is
diabetes down-regulating lxr but it's
also down regulating if you look at the
octave sterile form here it's done
regulating the activators the endogenous
activators 4lx are suggesting that tight
and this is armed just using a type 2
diabetic rap model suggesting that
diabetes is really having this negative
effect in pathways that are promoting
the export of cholesterol out of the
retina suggesting why you perhaps have
this high accumulation so the novelty of
my work in the Busic lab really stems
from identifying this novel signaling
pathway and that's what i'm going to be
showing evidence for up today so the one
player that we found that activates lxr
is tert one and this has been shown
previously to activate lxr in non
retinal systems but the work and the lab
that i've been doing really has shown
how this player really activates alex
are in the retina and activation of the
signaling complex which I show I hope to
convince you by the end of this
presentation really is a potential
therapy to stop the progression of
diabetic retinopathy so a little bit of
sir
this is a really interesting on enzyme
it is a member of the statue and family
so it is ni da plus dependent and it are
really involved in a flu of things as
you can see in this slide most relevant
to our my work I'm looking at the way
that it regulates metabolic syndromes
aging and of course diabetes so we have
shown with the same method that I
previously showed where that Lexar but
if you look at certain expression in the
diabetic retina is significantly
decrease in the diabetic condition so
the hypothesis is moving forward is that
you have the way that the mechanism
works is that you have activators such
as the octave sterile or pharmacological
activators of elux are they bind to lxr
and then this can cause the activation
of the reverse cholesterol transport
gene which then can eliminate
cholesterol but you can also repress
inflammatory genes and this is I just
want to spend a couple of seconds on
here because this is really important
this pathway is not only promoting
cholesterol a flux from their retina but
it's also repressing inflammation and
low-grade chronic inflammation is a
hallmark of diabetic retinopathy
progression so activating this pathway
is really exciting because you can kind
of do two things at once you can get rid
of the excess cholesterol but you can
also prevent inflammation so the idea as
a diabetic retinopathy decreases the
amount of Alex or activation which then
leads to this lipid emia by this
regulation of reverse cholesterol
transport and it also leads to
inflammation since you have an increase
in all of these markers which I have
highlighted here and of course that
would lead to dr progression so the bulk
of my work that looks at and de Sciglio
cells as I previously mentioned I do
this by doing a cell culture model these
are primary retina and sol cells and the
protocol I follow is this paper that
I've highlighted here in case anyone is
interested and basically we are generous
to have a meat lab on campus and we they
are generous with
samples and I am able to acquire bovine
eyes from them I then dissect the retina
as I'm shown me shown here and then this
are just the retina layer so I'm
focusing on the endothelial cells so we
then culture them the whole process
takes about 1 1 and a half weeks and
after that process you have these
beautiful endothelial cells which are
relatively easy to acquire they are
economical and they the most important
part is that they mimic what we're
seeing in the human in the human culture
and of course towards the end of the
studies we always do human cultures to
verify our effects that we're seeing
once we verify that these are in the
solar cells via two methods the first is
looking at LDL uptake so this is just a
positive control if you hit endothelial
cells with low density lipoprotein they
will take it up and that is shown here
with the images as well as a
quantification and we also do von
Willebrand factor see me again this is a
published showing that and this little
cells expressed just protein so you can
see here at different levels of
confluency they're all expressing BWS so
using this model system I've really been
able to dissect the way that lxr insert
one are activating a reverse cholesterol
transport and inflammation focusing on
RCT so here the top just shows the
schematic of what we believe is
happening so if you hit these cells with
a diabetic relevant stimuli and that is
with TNF alpha so one of the challenges
of culture systems is trying to find the
right stimulus to mimic what's happening
in a very complex in vivo system so here
TNF alpha is known to be upregulated in
human so we are using this model to
mimic the inflammation that we see in
the human eye so if you hit on the sauce
with TNF also you said there's a
decrease in Alex our signaling there's
also a decrease in ABC a1 which is part
of this reverse cholesterol transport as
well as ABC g1
so interestingly if you activate lxr
with DMHC a this is a selective agonist
for lxr so it is a just like the oxy
stairs are an endogenous activator this
is just a drug that you can treat the
sulphate and and it selectively activate
lxr so you can see again that you have
this decrease in a1 and g1 with tina
alpha but if you treat the south of DMHC
a even in the presence of TNF alpha you
can have an upregulation of a1 and g1
suggesting that if you were to treat an
animal or a patient that has this high
levels of TNF alpha or inflammation you
can maybe activate cholesterol reverse
um genes and then promote the effects of
cholesterol from the retina
looking at inflammation the other wing
of the pathway again you have this
massive increase without one beta in
both um so yeah so the left is at DMHC a
this is a selective lxr activator and
you have an increase in um at one beta
but then if you treat them with either
the DMHC a or the start 1720 now cert
seven to 20 is a selective search one
activator so here we're looking at the
role that cert one is playing so you can
either increase and you can treat them
with the Alex are activated on the left
or the cert one activated on the right
you can see that in both instances you
can prevent this increase in
inflammation that you're seeing because
of TNF alpha treatment now it's really
an exciting we see all of this on all of
these phenotypes in two cells but if you
move on to the animal model this is a
type 2 DB DB mouse model you see again
the increase in a cellular formation
these are the diabetic or untreated
animal but if you treat the animals at D
with gw3 965 another lxr activator and
we've actually done this to a DMHC and
see similar results you have a decrease
in this ACL or capillary formation and
that is quantified in this graph
suggesting that that all of the effect
that we're seeing in vitro and
preventing cholesterol a flock are
promoting cholesterol reflux and
preventing inflammation could somehow be
preventing the disease from advancing in
the animal so after this at work we
really became interested in trying to
find non pharmacological or different
ways of activating the pathway the MHC a
and GW are really great activators of
lxr but there's there are some adverse
effects and those include lipogenesis so
there's a lot since you're activating so
much our removal of cholesterol that
could have negative effects so I was
really interested in the role that sirt1
is having as a calorie sensing a
nutrient sensing enzyme so certain one
is activated in calorie restriction
environment and recently there has
really been a plethora of results and
interesting study is showing especially
a just recent calorie study showing the
the beneficial effect that fasting has
on aging and life span and prevention of
several metabolic induced diseases so
this really I was really interested by
this because if certain one is activated
and these calorie restriction nutrient
deprivation states could we then use
this model to activate cert one and then
ultimately activate cert one and then
this could see the give a similar effect
that we see in the animals when we're
activating lxr with
pharmacological means so this I led to
the hypothesis that perhaps the
observation could lead to the up
regulation of certain one I like star
signalling and thus prevent IDR
progression so to test that hypothesis I
again went back to the bovine and
authorial culture model and I treated
cells with your foot serum containing 0%
FBS and you can see here looking at pcr
so this is expression level 2 you have
an increase in step 1
you also have an increase in a1 and d1
and these two are the proteins involved
in the reverse cholesterol transport and
these are always used in in my studies
as a measure of Alex or activity so
we're suggesting that Alex our activity
is up and also it's really cool is that
you also have a decrease in B cam 1 and
this is a measure for inflammation so
here we're showing that if you simply
removed a serum from these cells for 24
hours you can have an increase in cert 1
lxr activity and and decrease in
inflammation and you also here I'm
showing evidence looking at their
activity so on the left you have
expression levels but if you also look
at how much the acidity histone
deacetylase activity you have in these
cells after Sam starvation which is the
light gray bar you have an increase and
the TNF alpha is a positive control
since we know that inflammation
decreases a check activity and that's
what on you're seeing here
moving on trying to really figure out if
sirt1 is mediating these effects what i
did was i with sRNA i got rid of cert
one and you can hear I'm looking at
cholesterol export so if you remove
start one but that's RNA from this
culture you lose this upregulation of a1
and g1 that you see as a result of serum
suggesting that certain one really is
playing this crucial role in modulating
the serum starvation effects so in
addition to modulating elect our
activity with some using a 1 and g1
we're also really interested in this
because it's also increasing LX our
protein levels and this is suggesting
that perhaps it's not only increasing
activity but it's also increasing the
amount of available lxr that is around
for certain one to activate it and we
are are currently working on publishing
these results in an upcoming study
so to summarize this portion we show
that fasting and sand salvation can't
increase cert 1 and increase lxr so once
you have increase in sir 1 you have an
increase in lxr activity and then that
can lead to decreases inflammation and
cholesterol East locks so suggesting
that start 1 is mediating this on serum
servation results and what's really
interesting about this is that when you
look at all of the fasting studies most
of them are mechanisms that are being
suggested to regulate these effects but
no one really knows how these beneficial
effects that we're seeing due to fasting
or happening so this work is exciting
because not only are we trying we are
suggesting a non pharmacological way to
activate these beneficial effects that
you see with a lexer activation but it's
also giving a mechanism of action or an
extort of an explanation to what is
happening with these beneficial fasting
induced effect that we see in humans and
non-human primates and cells and I'm a
slew of different organisms
and then this is a little teaser for my
paper that's coming up and we've
replicated this to the study inhuman
mice these were not diabetic mice isms
control mice and what we see is that
there are trends towards increased sirt1
activity and mice if you just simply
sass them for two weeks so a very short
fast can have really beneficial effects
and we also see this with our
collaborator and that work is arm
published they starved their their
diabetic animals for longer periods of
time loops I believe it was six months
and those animals actually the fasted
animals were no longer had to add AG
retinopathy so they did not it was not a
cert one story but that just shows
evidence that this fasting protocols are
really beneficial in preventing dr and
the other diabetic retinopathy
pathologies
yeah so in summary I just want to
highlight one more time the beneficial
effects of elux are activation whether
it is through the MHC a or 1720 or
sterols or the serum storm starvation
data so the idea is that if you activate
the pathway you're going to activate the
reverse cholesterol transport which is
going to regulate lipid metabolism and
you're also going to repress this
inflammatory genes which is going to get
rid of that pro-inflammatory low-grade
inflammation that you see in diabetic
retinopathy and I would that I would
like to thank everyone who helped me
with this work on specifically everyone
in the Busic lab Tod lytic who helped
with all of the retinal cholesterol
measurement in the animal the grant lab
they are the ones that are really
focused on the fasting side of it and
they that's the paper that I referenced
earlier and they have done a great job
characterizing intermittent fasting in
diabetic retinopathy progression as well
as our funding sources and if I would
love to hear from you if you have any
questions please contact me I have my
email and my Twitter handle here and
with that I will be very happy to take
any questions thank you so much
Thank You dr. hammer for your
informative presentation yes now it is
time to start our life to an a portion
of our webinar to our audience if you
have an audio if you have a question you
would like to ask please do so now just
click on that ask a question box located
on the far left of your screen and we
will answer as many of your questions as
we have time for to have some great
questions coming in dr. Henry let's
start with this one does serum
starvation modulate lxr activity that is
dependent on sirt1 great thanks at
Christie so as a question I don't want
to say this completely dependent on
start one but I do have some work
showing that if you get rid of start one
with Si RNA you lose the beneficial
effects that you see with a1 and g1
upregulation as a result of stem
starvation so although it might not be
completely dependent we do have some
evidence showing that it is playing that
signaling pathway it is playing a
significant role in this
you let us know if serum starvation can
affect cell death right yeah so that is
a kind of the question that I get asked
a lot so if you are removing serum you
would maybe think that you could be
effecting a cell death and we've looked
at this in our retina no cilia cells and
what we see is that there's no change in
cell death after 24 hours however if you
leave them in this serum starvation
media for longer then I think I've gone
out to 96 hours then you do start to see
cell death at that extended period of
time
but at our time points which are 24
hours we do not see any cell death and
we've also looked at other on health
functions such as mitochondria
respiration and there is no difference
in that measure either
Thank You dr. hammer we have a question
coming in what is the role of rxr insert
one
so that that's a ninja question so I'm
not too familiar with the role of start
one and rxr I do know that LX ARS form a
heterodimer with the retinoid x receptor
which is the RX r and these are in the
literature known as an oblique eight
partner so this has to be on this header
driver has to be form in order for LX r
to transcribe abca1 and g1 and other on
targets I'm not sure however how that
interaction is playing with start one it
would be interesting to see if one start
1d isolates LX r if that interaction
with the arcs are is no longer needed or
is it altered
anyway but it is an interesting question
to further investigate
the systemic cholesterol effect retinal
cholesterol levels
the reason why I pause for that habit so
at the lair of the quarry okay Polaris
facing the rpe has openings that enable
the delivery of nutrients and from the
systemic circulation so we do know that
the systemic circulation the available
of cholesterol and the stomach
circulation could affect the RPE intake
of cholesterol but we've also seen
clinical trials where systemic control
of cholesterol has not been beneficial
in helping patients that have diabetic
retinopathy and that is why we think
that the way to modulate the cholesterol
levels is to really locally do this so
we want to directly target the
cholesterol levels in the retina as
opposed to globally treating the
cholesterol increases since we do have
evidence from human clinical trials that
have shown that if you do that if you go
that route you don't really have an
effect to the cholesterol levels in the
retina so we really want to we're
talking about cholesterol in there right
now we really want to focus to the
tissues specific rather than going the
systemic row
Thank You dr. hammer now when you talk
about fasting for how many hours a day
so when we talk about ourselves so if
you just looking at a petri dish and so
I did my studies for 24 hours if you are
talking about animals we have fashion
studies that range from I've seen from
two weeks all the way to extended
periods like six months if you're
talking about humans that is a
completely different system so there are
many different regimens out there and we
are not really suggesting that this is
something that should be done in the
human system we are just providing some
evidence for the beneficial effects of
modulating cholesterol so there is
really a wide range of stuff that needs
to happen before we can really suggest a
fasting regimen or something that would
work in humans but in animals there's
really a long really wide difference and
studies that have shown beneficial
effects and I really think it's going to
come down to the individual person
rather than just having one protocol
that really works for everyone
now while we're on the topic of fasting
how is caloric restriction different
from intermittent fasting so um calorie
restriction and intermittent fasting
these have been kind of a hot topic for
a while in research and in medicine and
calorie restriction that's one of this
research dates back many many years and
when you look at the animals or like I
mentioned in the talk looking from cells
all the way to non-human primates if you
do calorie searching studies you can
prevent aging you can prevent a wide
range of metabolic associated syndromes
however it is really hard to implement
in human since there are negative
effects that have been associated with
calorie restrictions such as
malnutrition uh problems when it comes
to on fertility things like that so
intermittent fasting seems to provide a
more approachable way of implementing
the positive effect you have from
calorie restriction so intermittent
fasting simply means that you are
modulating the amount of nutrition to a
specific time and sometimes I would say
most of the time that does come with
some sort of less calorie intake but not
necessarily and the benefits of benjamín
fasting is that you have the periods
where you are normally consuming meals
followed by a period where you're not so
you have that active recovery stage and
you are allowed the metabolism to kind
of recover from that calorie restore
that no nutrient intake when you are
feeding as opposed to calorie
restriction which is a more dramatic way
to cut down how much a nutrient you're
consuming
no products Inchon up sorry so and nota
National the National Institute of Aging
has a really nice section on their
website on the benefits of calorie
restriction and instrument fasting and
they also have all of the studies that
have been done to really back those
claims up so it's a wonderful resource
for someone who has more questions about
this on that topic
great doctor Hummer could you repeat
that website again or where we could
find that is that yes it's the National
Institute of Aging it's on through the
NIH and you can just do on a Aging
Institute at the NIH and it should come
up excellent thanks so much
now our next question there are animal
and human studies that suggest cert one
is activated by invoking intermittent
fasting carbohydrate restriction ketosis
and/or exercise do you have any idea how
the other protocols affect lxr
yeah so
so since lxr has two arms of its pathway
I could also imagine Alex are having
this beneficial overall effect by
modulating the low-grade chronic
inflammation so that is kind of the one
pathway that my mind is going to I'm
sure there's other mechanisms that it
could be having its positive effects but
really by not only promoting the
cholesterol a flux but also getting rid
of this on low-grade chronic
inflammation could be another mechanism
of action that Wistar want or not would
serve one independent up that warrant
could be having these beneficial effects
mmm
I hope that answered your question
thank you have you looked at other
markers aside from il-1 be to measure
inflammation
yes we've looked at aisle six
and we've looked at V cam and I cam and
we see similar effects with inflammation
we want to in a way that we have seen
before is that it has to be it doesn't
have to be but we have looked at all the
ones that are NF kappa-b dependence and
that is the one that we've seen
previously published at XR is having a
direct effect but yeah so we've looked
at all 6 v cam I cam and we've also
loaded MC P 1 and we have if all of
these are also highlighted in the hammer
2017 a bio biomedicine manuscript and we
have more on markers as shown there
okay let's go to this question let's see
can you explain to us how LX r and r XR
work
yeah so I don't know too much about rxr
I do know that it does in order for lxr
to act activate a 1 and g1 for instance
those it's downstream targets it has to
form a heterodimer with rxr now I don't
know if this interaction is necessary
once start 1 deescalate lxr or if so if
one step 1 deficits are is it necessary
to form the timer I'm not sure it would
be it would be interesting to definitely
look at that that Bob I'm not going to
them for sure
now you mentioned adverse effects to lxr
activators can you explain what these
are
right so one of them the main one is
that it provides activation of art on
SRS bp1 and this can lead to lipogenesis
so you don't want that occurring that
could be very bad and that's actually
why some of the the studies looking at
LX are activators and humans have not
gone very well
because of that negative effect on the
sterol regulatory element binding
protein and yeah so that's kind of the
main one
Thank You dr. hammer now do you have any
final comments for our audience
and I would mostly just want to thank
everyone for registering and for
listening to my presentation and if you
would like if you have any other
questions or would like to ask me
anything that my email is shown here and
also my Twitter handle and I would love
to hear from review and just wanting to
give a one last shout out to my pi/4 the
support not only in the lab but also
supporting me with this webinar and it's
been really nice to have that support
from the lab so I just want to thank
that and um get Co and my Christi for
this opportunity has been a lot of fun
and I really appreciate it
like to thank you again dr. hammer for
your time today and for your important
research we would also like to thank lab
roots and our sponsor Thermo Fisher
Scientific for underwriting today's
educational webcast and before we go we
would like to do one more thank you to
our audience for joining us today and
for their interesting questions now we
have a few questions we weren't able to
answer today and any of those questions
submitted during the on demand period
will be addressed by dr. hammer via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration this webcast can be
viewed on-demand and mavericks will
alert you via email when it's available
for replay we encourage you to share
that email with your colleagues who may
have missed today's live event you will
now be redirected to the registration
page of our next webinar titled in
automated cancer organized
to accelerate research and drug
screening presented by Brooke Schuster
on January 30th at 9:00 a.m. Pacific
time 12:00 p.m. Eastern Time we hope to
see you there that's all for now and
have a great day